[Musique]
j'ai toujours été un enfant très très
très anxieux ma mère me l'a toujours dit
faire de la peinture c'est la solution
qu'elle a trouvée pour apprivoiser les
angoisses la maladie mentale s'était pas
remis de l'argent comme aujourd'hui
cette jeune femme de 26 ans souffre d'un
trouble anxieux généralisé
elle préfère garder l'anonymat entre
autres pour ne pas subir les préjudices
d'éventuels employeurs l'anxiété sais
c'est pas contrôlable pis tu sais pas
pourquoi tu se réfléchit tente ici de
tout le pays votre jour arriver ça
tourne en rond
ça devient fatiguant aussi parce que
t'es pas capable d'arrêter de réfléchi
fait que j'ai j'ai craqué après avoir
reçu le diagnostic l'an dernier le
médecin lui accorder un arrêt de travail
de trois mois est paralysée sata part de
tout allait dans le métro ça m'a demandé
de l'énergie cet épisode a laissé une
tache dans son dossier médical
en magasinant des assurances assurance
vie assurance médicale et dentaire
elle a eu la mauvaise surprise de
constater que personne ne veulent
assurer écoute je peux pas assuré t
refusé que je fais je suis refusé pour
l'invalidité vent doutait non non tout
ton dossier n'est pas admis c'est avec
les cheveux en effet pourquoi n'est-elle
pas admissible nous avons posé la
question à l'association qui représente
les assureurs au canada dans le cadre
d'un problème de maladie mentale
malheureusement on peut penser que les
données démontrent que statistiquement
les gens qui ont le jeu trouble risque
ou de se suicider ou d'avoir des
comportements liés à leur maladie qui
font en sorte qu'ils sont à risque de
décéder plus rapidement et les
compagnies d'assurances puisqu'il s'agit
d'entreprises privées ont tout à fait le
droit de refuser un client comme toute
organisation privée
il se donne des règles et il fonctionne
avec leurs propres rêves par contre ça
break légal est-ce que c'est moral doris
provencher travaille dans le domaine
depuis plus de 30 ans elle a rencontré
plusieurs personnes dans cette situation
incapable de s'assurer
elle se souvient tout particulièrement
du cas d'un député qui témoigne en
commission parlementaire au début des
années 2000 je fais un épuisement
professionnel
2001 sur j'ai travaillé comme consultant
l'année dernière je me suis acheté une
maison
effectivement j'ai pas d'assurance
hypothécaire daniel bernard arabe et à
rouyn noranda il a finalement obtenu une
assurance pour l'hypothèque de sa maison
toutes ces années plus tard il constate
qu'on parle davantage de santé mentale
mais ceux qui demandent de l'aide sont
pénalisés selon lui on est un peu coincé
situerait pas au pot au questionnaire ce
dans un certain corps où tu mets sur un
questionnaire ça peut très très peu plus
tard il faut être transparent mais
c'était c'est à double tranchant faire
je me suis fait dire c'est comme si tu
avais la jambe cassée ces sites avaient
l'argent quand c'est vrai faire soigner
mais là c'est dans ta tête faut
peut-être faire soigner oui mais se
pourrait que la société est rendu là les
mentalités changent t'elles trop
lentement le monde de l'assurance se
défend la science évolue le traitement
des maladies mentales s'améliore et
c'est une très très bonne chose et
peut-être à un moment donné ces gens là
vont pouvoir être assurables comme s'il
n'avait pas souffert de maladies comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui pour les gens
porteurs du vih ou même dans certains
cas pour certaines personnes qui ont eu
un cancer
j'ai tout fait c'est gégé pain j'ai fait
du yoga j'ai eu à demander le sport ne
sera pas le sommeil la nutrition giteau
de fait ça l'a aidé mais j'avais besoin
de médication
c'est notamment pour ça qu'elle aimerait
avoir une assurance pour payer sa
médication les consultations chez le
psychologue mais d'ici là elle n'est pas
au bout de ses peines